what of luck worked out with Jordan this
morning here in the West Coast anyway on
today's day only be we go into a keynote
I did with Chase Jarvis at the kind of a
photography summit obviously the world
of photography has been destructed
Mendeley over the last decade and this
talk I think covers a ton of that so for
your creative friends make sure they
listen to this hope you enjoy
[Music]
hello say hi to your neighbor for a
second you guys look all scared
introduce yourself
alright alright
I'm a starting-off since I guess I'm
I've been a part of the photo industry
for as long as I can remember I think
it's really important to understand that
craft plays a really important role in
the life that you all have chosen to
lead you have to be good at it but just
like professional golf that say there's
300 people who play in the PGA you can
only name two or three and everything
beyond craft is what will help you you
have to have craft to get in the door
but if you don't have all the other
stuff it's gonna be very hard to make
the living and more importantly the life
that you want and we are Cokie noting
today in part because I realized over my
career the first time I came here I
showed pictures the second time I came
here I showed pictures and told stories
the third time I came here on this stage
third time I keynoted I showed the
pictures and videos and told stories and
talked about social media and the fourth
time I came here it was I've been here a
lot port that I came here it was all
about outside influences and if there's
everything all the first one through
five
I feel like got picked up and absorbed
and internalized from you know the
hundreds of folks were sitting in the
audience today and the thousands of
people who are watching these videos
after we post them but what has not been
internalized is that the best
information influence ideas strategies
creative inspiration comes from outside
the industry it comes from outside if
you're all looking at the person next to
you for inspiration and they're looking
to you what happens it's just a circle
and I've seen that and some I've taken a
my life mission with creativeLIVE with
my show chase Travis live and in part of
a hanging around with with people like
Gary and others to bring that
inspiration into our industry I feel
like it's the number one thing that's
ignored and
this particular human has had a huge
influence on me on popular culture in
general and so I thought it'd be good if
if the biggest service that I could be
in service of this community would be to
let you hear from someone who wouldn't
normally be here at this place so with
that I'm gonna give you a question we're
in conversation this is the longest
you've been quiet
probably I'm literally bleeding and as
I'm biting my tongue so hard that was
super hard
it gives them introductory or Marcy say
some please yes first of all I'm very
very humbled and flattered to be here in
this community I think all sub
communities are super fascinating they
have their own DNA their own beating
heart I have had the luxury in the last
seven years to build a creative agency
you know vaynermedia has 300 creatives
that work for us across many different
offices and the thing that I've been
most fascinated by is the thing that
connects all of us regardless if we're
in this industry entrepreneurs traders
mothers and parents you know piano
players or traders on Wall Street
whatever it is whatever it is what has
been very fascinating to me in this
space is ego ego is a killer you know i
I've been really thinking about coming
here this morning and and I was like I
really want to bring value I hope I say
something that really helps somebody and
when things change and we're living in a
very changing world
a lot of our contemporaries maybe the
people you looked up to or your
grandparents that also did this kind of
work creative work they had a data they
had a strength or a weakness a luxury or
an issue depending on how you look at
the world their world stayed firm and
stable for a long time we do not have
that luxury we're living during a great
revolution it's called the Internet it's
now 20 years old having a consumer side
and it is the biggest shift to our
culture on a human level let alone on a
creative level and what it's done is the
following its eliminated gatekeepers
the Internet is the middleman and so if
I can leave you with anything I
genuinely believe the thing that has
helped me be successful
in my trade is that I deploy
unbelievable amounts of humility for all
my cockiness around one thing the market
is the judge in the jury not me and I
think that in the creative field the
thing that has hurt so many people I
care about
is they want to rest on experience or
awards that are arbitrary by the way or
degrees or something other than the
market you may not like it but the
market always chooses so if I'm gonna
pick up on that threat for a second I
think that's that's part of what I when
I meant in like what was when I would
speak what would be absorbed and I think
there's also this dramatic hesitation
that you know a lot of people say I
can't do this I'm not this there's some
punk who's 17 years old with a camera
and she's gonna kick my ass and and
you're giving away trade secrets and
it's unfair and I think as photographers
when I came into the history a long time
ago it was very much close it was about
secrets and I'm not going to bring in a
an assistant because they're gonna learn
from me and they're gonna learn my
special lighting stuff and then they're
gonna go out and then they're gonna use
that against me
to take money I've literally had death
threats and yeah and I'm not trying to
over dramatize it but well you're a
pretty bad guy
from people who've said that I'm taking
money by creativeLIVE we have given away
three or four billion minutes of free
education and the Internet has given
away way more yes for sure this is like
like I don't understand what people are
debating yeah like information has been
commoditized you have to wrap your head
around it yeah that's just what I mean
you're more than welcome to live in your
own head and create excuses the problem
is nobody gives a [ __ ] like I mean like
it is what it is
like like I wish that email didn't
become not as popular I built my first
business on it I wish the Twitter was
still number one I was one of the first
people with a million followers I wish I
wish I wish my the only reason that I
have the great honor to sit on this
stage right now is because I give away
all my best advice for free every single
day you're welcome you're welcome at it
let me let me tell you a couple things
that may you may find unbelievably
powerful and maybe a shift and I speak
to somebody in their 40s like me 50 60
70 s because your habits are formed let
me say something that might be a huge
unlock 99% of people don't do anything
about the free information the reason I
give away all my best stuff is because
nobody does anything about it which
leaves plenty for me to still do yeah
and and for the 1% that do those become
your new friends those are your peers
let me people you love let me tell you
one other thing about those 1% they were
gonna win anyway you can't stop winners
from winning my friends and then you can
educate the other 99% and get all the
admiration and leave a wonderful legacy
and live a fulfilled life that's the
model as it as the creative donor of a
creative agency I want to shift gears
into specifically you you were a lot of
people who create media and what's what
is your number one piece of advice
besides being grateful and besides
letting them making sure that you
understand that the market is right what
is what is a tactic that you feel like
this audience by and large is getting
wrong be in the yes business be in the
yes business Instagram yes filters yes
going live yes snapchat yes pph yes BR
yes
vr yes yes yes yes why are you so fancy
with your time like really you don't
have time for this but yet you have the
ambition to get the luxuries that come
along with being independent we do not
map our mouth excuse me we do not map
our actions to our mouths if you have
aspirations to win to crush it to do it
the way you want to do it you need to be
in the yes business I at this point have
achieved enormous things and every day I
deploy humility to download a new app
and taste it and waste my time because I
know I learn every time I know the
markets moving and I'm stunned by how
many creatives master a skill and then
try to milk it for 47 years that's not
the reality that we're doing yeah and so
you need to be in the yes business yet I
see creatives always saying no and they
come up with some arbitrary [ __ ] of
why it's not pure and then they get run
over so a little bit about the format if
you're thinking that some of this might
be resonating with you at some point in
the next I don't know I have no idea how
much time we have we could talk all day
I think you guys know us but at some
point yeah what 40 40 okay right now
some of you're going like oh [ __ ] 40
more minutes of this hopefully if you've
done that you've lost yeah that's that's
exactly that don't got time for this
thing this seat right here is reserved
for a couple of people that would like
actual information from he and I
one-on-one in real time so if you think
you have a problem that you would like
to have solved I would like we're going
to do a couple of these throughout the
threat to 40 minutes here so I would
like one person and we'll know I like
Gary big invited him fucking-a we got it
right here
how are you okay now you all right we
got to get this gentleman microphone if
we can while we're finding a mic for you
I'm gonna I'll talk slowly so we can get
you a mic I see it coming you you're up
here not just to hang out okay
you're up here because what I believe
there's about a hundred problems that we
all have as humans we all have about 100
problems and they can be in very you
know they gate in various different
camps but we're gonna try
we got time for that [ __ ] later oh yeah
there you go
but what we're gonna do yeah they'll
turn it on just talk let me hear your
name yes hello I'm Jason McCoy from
Jason McCoy photography in Chicago
Illinois give it up to Jason all right
Jason welcome what's your biggest
challenge right now I think my biggest
challenge now is I'm sort of being
handsome they called me sexy chocolate
listen ya know my biggest challenge now
is trading money for time so I don't
have a problem getting people in my
studio okay
now it's like okay I'd only do maybe two
shoots a day yeah I want to make more
money but I'm maxing out one just time I
don't want to work 24 raise your prices
yeah ten what happened ten extra prices
tomorrow I'm serious as a heart attack
if you 10x your ear it's your rates try
it
10x ax I say this on the internet about
twice a week I get pages from people who
are like holy [ __ ] i 10x my rates and
I'm still busy
they literally ten and here's the good
part for everybody if nobody's paying
that means the markets answering but
guess what you know what's better than
the same rate two extra rates yeah maybe
you couldn't get the ten maybe your
market wasn't there maybe your location
wasn't there maybe your talent wasn't
there maybe your brand wasn't there but
you know what's better than a dollar two
dollars let me ask
questions so why do you charge today
what you charge where did you get that
information well where did I get that
information so I have reviewed other
photographers there in my area yep and
then I pretty much reviewed other
photographers at that area I know I
don't do commercial work I do strictly
portrait okay um and my price for some
people are saying it's some people say
it's too high
yep and other people people say oh it
was just as much so I got a I'm in a
middle how many of the people that said
it was too high still did it 20% 10% 50%
I have people say you know I saved up
for this shoot so this means a lot for
me to come in here okay so I've had that
so I don't know how you know yes I want
I want every person to be right on the
edge of saying no and just deciding to
say yes because you're worth it and if
you can't figure out that sweet prices I
don't have a price I don't say my rates
are $250 you in some industries you
should but I always want to find out
what the upper limit of my client is and
what they are going to value me if you
have a if you're a $500 photographer you
will always be a $500 photographer and
for the client that says you're gonna be
oh when I get more money I'll come back
[ __ ] because when they find $5,000
that they can they go to a $500
photographer no [ __ ] way
they're gonna go to the person who is 10
grand and they'll try and talk them into
doing it for five sees you I just get in
there get in there you know I just
wanted to say to you and everybody else
never say no for the other guy I don't
think that means I'll explain it good
good so I would that's why I was with
this erratic boss yeah here's what I
mean my mouth here's what I mean my
bakit a lot of people talk themselves
out of a higher price oh I can't be 800
cuz Rick who I think is better as 650
that means you're saying no for the
other person keep pushing the envelope
let some people say no it's listen
almost everything's about
in demand you don't know what your
demand cost is until you push the
envelope the way I learned my price is
speaking when I started getting put on
in 2009 intent or is the same I just
kept asking for more every time and then
when I got 11 knows in a row for 50,000
I'm like I guess I'm 40,000 but that was
a lot more than the 5,000 that I was
thrilled to get for a speech right and
so you it is detrimental to not continue
to ask more every single time and just
keep going on it here's the funny part
hello it's Jason how much is it 800 oh
that's too much
700 oh that's look like you you you're
just playing a game of chicken yeah like
like going higher even if they start
seeing you're coming down you can
eventually say no to like you're so in
control yeah yet it's insecurity that's
driving down your price I got I think
that's brilliant I gotta hop on the back
side of that and say are all of these
clients the same amount good for you no
stuck some suck so when the ones that
sucked call back at that shitty price
that you're charging and that's the one
where you say oh man sorry my rates have
doubled I'm super busy I really
appreciate you that you don't say eff
off you say oh I'm so busy I'm sorry my
rates are double and 10% of those people
are gonna go okay I still need it and
you're like okay that client is becoming
a nun okay Chloe it's the happiness cash
ratio well question being so I have
clients of various financial means yeah
so if I have a plan who's a millionaire
versus the client who's barely can
afford this shouldn't I give equal rates
to everyone or first of all no
Wow Jason Jason and the answer is
shouldn't you according to WHO who's the
judge in the jury of this shouldn't you
if you want to by the way I say yes I've
lived my life by giving different prices
based on people's financial situation
because it just makes me feel good like
and by the way I don't think you're
wrong
it's just I'm asking everybody based on
what that's why I swear he got an
information where did he get his pricing
information he got it from the market he
looked around and said I'm just like
everybody else if Tommy's tan and I'm 2
or and Sally's 2 then I'm right here in
the middle Jason if you want to be Robin
Hood and charge 4x for people that you
think are rich so that you can do right
by certain other people Mazel Tov hey
let's give it up for me
a stand-up we should turn around
actually with the crowd oh good idea
let's get the crowd I'm a professional
photographer yeah I have no idea what
the [ __ ] I'm doing one more round of
applause for me oh thank you all right
so might we're gonna all in just one
second so the plan here is actual value
at what I loved about that is raise your
hand if you have had a pricing thought
in your brain that confused you just
like that of course that's the 90
percent of the room ten percent Liars
yeah all right give us another framework
for how you're thinking that you see
folks in the creative communities not
thinking garry attention arbitrage so if
I can have you lead with anything about
arbitrage is a bank thing they don't
understand it understood I mean I'm not
saying you like like we as an industry a
noodle I don't understand arbitrage the
word either but I know what I'm trying
to say but the chance I'm just trying to
be like let's keep it real like it's not
use big words I failed every English
class I took so I'm proud that I get the
right token as a as a big word user very
simple there's over priced and under
priced attention as a collective of the
human race right now there are places
where people perceive a lot of people
are paying attention to and they're not
television commercials print advertising
print other things and there's
underpriced attention that we haven't
wrapped our head around even big things
like Facebook and Instagram and
influencers so I think a lot of
creatives aren't being strategic enough
about building up their brand or
awareness for what they do by creating
work in places where people are actually
paying attention versus what they grew
up putting on a pedestal
I'd much rather and by the way this is
not even close I would much rather be on
chases show then interviewed in the Wall
Street Journal it's not even close
that's [ __ ] crazy right
well you're welcome what
if you want to sell something you're far
I mean there's no cook yeah I can be on
CNBC CNN Fox and the Today Show and I
would sell ten times X my awareness of
whatever I was talking about then if I
just did Malcolm Gladwell's podcast
there's an amazing arbitrage a shift an
amazing dynamic of the attention and
listen I get covered by print New York
Times and then some kid puts a photo of
me on Instagram I'm living it I know
what's going on the attention has
shifted on you at a level and when I say
you I don't mean the photography
creative sector I mean us humans the
attention is shifted so quickly so
extremely that if you're a practitioner
if you start thinking about where it
really is an amazing unlock for the
things that you want for you and your
family comes from that world and that
I'll pick it back on that this is very
important to me you may not know what
that means you're a creative you're an
artist but it's scary to me that you
could spend five hours on youtube and
google searching things based on what I
just said and get educated in five hours
that can disproportionately change your
life like when people like well I don't
get it like cool go Google what's
happening on Facebook how do I get more
people to pay attention to me on
Instagram the information is free you
don't have to go to a [ __ ] library
you can do it in your underpants at 2:00
a.m. in your bed and it
disproportionally can change your life
um we are so blessed and so lucky and
people are choosing pessimism over
optimism and it baffles me
how about you what is you know let's
reverse it somebody who has deep context
into this community teacher give me the
last six months from your perspective as
a thought leader as a practitioner of
the craft let's make it very narrow sure
to buy you a few more seconds here in
the last six months what's been an
interesting trend what's a meme with a
subculture like what's happening what's
happening is the industry is polarizing
so there's more photographs being bought
and sold now than ever before
amazing like that was an accident but
that's what 2 or 3 billion photos get
uploaded every day the photographers are
sitting in this room think that the
industry is sinking the reality is
there's more people buying there's more
money in the industry now than ever
before and people don't understand it
they don't know it so what's happening
is the the middle is falling out if your
beige or your gray or you're in the
middle nobody [ __ ] cares so be you do
want to be down here in the market doing
high-volume with a lot of stuff and
doing thousand-dollar influence or [ __ ]
with your Instagram and you can print
money that way or your super high-end
working for the people who are if you're
a trusted you've been in this business
for a long time and you can
disproportionately prove that you can do
it because when someone hires you
they're signing up it's on their ass and
if you can live in that camp
you can print money and if you're in the
middle trying to do the same [ __ ] you
did six months or six weeks or two years
ago you're gonna get eaten alive and
it's now in the last six months it's
just like it used to be going like this
and now it and anything in here this is
beige and gray and people I prescribe
being different not just better so this
is apathy of the same you either got a
you got to do this with intention don't
just say I don't know who I am I don't
know what I stand for I don't know who
my customers are figure it out and
over-index on that if you feel like
you're in the gray I've got a little
tactical thing that might help you when
this happens in markets and this is a
classic business thing that always
happens it's why you're gonna see so
many of your favorite retail stores go
out of business over the next five years
Toys R Us and Lord & Taylor's is the
preview literally 90% of the retailers
you know are gonna be out in the next
ten years because ecommerce got big
enough that it all broke and
that's what's happened with a supply and
demand of photography yeah here's an
incredibly optimistic thing to do this
is exactly the moment for you to take a
step back if you feel you're in a beige
and you're vulnerable I've got something
really fun take a step back and become a
super narrow niche expert in a certain
genre aka 1982-1984 Smurf
dynamics and this is gonna be really fun
because if you love your craft and you
have other interests this is where you
get real real real narrow let me give
you something super weird I take photos
of high school wide receivers now that
is narrow but you have to understand why
it's powerful on the human psychology
most parents think their kids in high
school that played football are gonna
play in the NFL
they're delirious right which means it's
a huge market which means that and I
know how narrow that is but if you love
high school football if you live in
Texas and it's religion like you will
find unbelievable opportunity when you
react to expansion you have to contract
what's amazing is you can contract in
something you've always loved t you love
t go deep into t take a photo of every
pea leaf ever from every [ __ ] angle
ever I'm telling you I'm telling you
I've seen this over and over it is this
true pattern recognition this is not my
intuition this could be an incredible
keynote for you because you're gonna win
twice you get to be fruitful in your
craft and you get to do it around the
thing that you most now really love
spoken and well and and and maybe you
hate Instagram today but Instagram can
help you so much because what you can do
is you can start taking three photos a
day posting on Instagram and using 1015
hashtags around tea chamomile black tea
some of what like you can do it and
people will start discovering you and
then if you actually put in work to
actually make your life happen and spend
another hour going to all the other tea
photos and adding your two cents
commenting becoming part of the
community you will be baffled by what
happen all of a sudden in in a six month
period you've got 11 different key
companies asking you to take the
official shot that they're putting on
their package then one of them becomes a
big t brand and you get to live the rest
of your life walking around and seeing
your picture I mean this is real what
I'm telling you
and notice how interesting it is and I
know you clapped and you really caught
my attention I appreciate it this is
where optimism beats pessimism woe is me
all these [ __ ] faces with a [ __ ]
iPhone have taken everything away from
me or holy [ __ ]
I can take photos of cocker spaniels for
the rest of my [ __ ] life that is
binary all right should we do another
hot seat yeah all right you're calling
it Gary time is short
hustle up we got this come on welcome
her to the stage you guys come on let's
go I have a gift for you tell us who you
are welcome put that thing right up
there I'm the least capable photographer
in this whole [ __ ] place okay my name
is Nikki I am a West Milford Beiste New
Jersey Jersey in the house Jersey in the
house we are the same age and I know I
look great so um I'm really glad that I
got asked to be up here after that exact
question because this is what I have
done in the last six months I went super
narrow I am now a yoga portrait
photographer love it boom how's business
I would call that narrow super narrow is
I take photos of people with playing
orally blonde hair that do yoga I'm just
telling you well a pedometer is provided
we've been women I've heard okay great
so what I have done because you said
that nobody listens to you yep I um
pretty much dropped out doing my
portrait business
and I still pick it up if people call me
but I'm not pursuing it are you charging
more now um well this where I'm at this
is where I'm at because six months ago I
decided about a year ago today that from
10x from reading 10x that I wanted to do
500 shoots in one year okay and I am now
at shoot I did shoot 372 this morning
I'll do the work yeah and I you better
hurry the [ __ ] up because you're running
behind I am running behind I wanted I
punted a few weeks so and it's the
holidays [ __ ] Thanksgiving that we do
not wanna be beefed up yeah so anyway no
freebies up here there no previous well
that was the problem I've been doing
freebies I've been reaching out which is
another thing I saw I'm selling [ __ ] on
eBay
yeah that I can keep the money
challenged maybe and I am reaching out
to people on Instagram saying I'll shoot
you for free I'll shoot you for free
I'll shoot you for free
yeah my going down city's sliding in
this morning shoot she has 49 thousand
followers great so the thing in question
is now chasing another puncher yeah I
know you're great when when do I start
saying [ __ ] you painting
hold tight girl yeah yeah I would say
tomorrow but here's the thing if you're
busy doing that thing you should start
charging for it immediately well what
else I heard in there and this is the
thing that most of you are I'm having
been in your shoes I know that what
you're saying right now is like yeah but
I make 95% of my money off weddings
should I just shut down my wedding
business nope there's a lot of heads
nodding out there cuz like I want to do
this thing I want to get no no I want to
get paid yes exactly like I am taking
money like I photograph the preschool
last week right it's like I still have
the stuff on the side I'm not posting
that on my Instagram page goods correct
specifically for the carpet got that is
that's the key right there she's not
being she's not showing pictures of
things she doesn't want to get higher I
have other accounts like I have an
account well that I have my travel
photography she's selling in one place
she's branding in another right okay
okay but my thing is when
like I'm reaching out to all these
people they're finally saying yes but
now I'm feeling like I'm starting to get
used no no like where you're using them
okay be careful yeah this is this you're
like - using them you had an agenda you
had an ambition you're trying to build
brand so you reached out to them you're
using them okay until you say there's a
price to it they're not taking advantage
of it they're saying yes to you taking
advantage of them but now the only
people reach out to me like Gary I'll
shoot you I'll do this you're gonna
leverage my brand to build your business
and that makes me happy okay but I'm not
taking advantage of you well no because
now it's like there's companies that are
like saying alright well cuz I was
thinking okay well maybe there's a like
a commercial aspect of it yeah so I'll
get a yoga company to send me stuff or
they'll send the models it off I don't
photograph them and they'll be like okay
well can I work on the next campaign or
I want to do this and they're like no we
just want you know your images like so
that's where that I tell you something
go ahead you're in control yeah you if
when the yoga company hits you up and
says we'd like to send you a yoga mat to
using this next thing you say cool a
thousand dollars okay
and when they say [ __ ] you you move on
to the next one that's what I've been
doing yeah good it's going to that point
okay but what Mazel Tov yeah this is the
thing though how scared are you that
you're never gonna make money
berry-berry right anybody else out there
ever been scary
do you understand we're all in this [ __ ]
together her psychology her challenges
are yours so if you're not paying
attention and that's literally the
function of this thing we're doing right
here what I like you to know the best
what's it like you age the best
businesses but this is what I want you
to know that you have what I hear
ambiguity like you don't know how you're
done right exactly and I've been talking
to you like a couple of my friends about
it I'm like what do I like we're here
we're gonna help we're gonna help but
here's something more important than us
being here we're about to leave right
and so the key is I'm about to go home
to records and it can be 2:17 it was
nicely ever on the stage with Carrie and
chase but now it's [ __ ] what do I do now
right it's very simple this [ __ ] is
binary either you ask for money or you
don't I literally came here to ask you
that because it was like I I was doing
it and doing it and do it and I'm like
okay but but like okay I get the
patience thing the piece can I go back
and I say something I'm the person that
can hold their breath the longest wins
yes so if you can afford to keep doing
nursery school and Shamar Suri school
and all that for three or four years
you're gonna continue to build brand and
have more leverage
don't let your other business on fire
just don't talk about it all that much
right okay
sales and branding yep you're building
something over here you're simmering
your [ __ ] over here I don't care if this
is a full-time job or if it's shooting
weddings or whatever you want to shoot
automotive you want to shoot you know
women and yoga pants
and look I get it let's talk about a
year from I'm serious like that is the
thing that you you have to be
intentional my biggest fear is I listen
I stand up thousands of people
eyeball-to-eyeball people don't actually
know what they want or if they know what
they want they're afraid to say it you
when we leave here today you go home and
you look in the mirror and you say
exactly what you want to do and you
commit to that and that what I'm hearing
it could be different but what I'm
hearing is that you want to put images
into the marketplace that are beautiful
images of yoga and then you want the
commercial relationship with the yoga
brands have you tried that do you
believe that have you said it over and
over and over again yeah and all you
need to get paid is like whoa like all
you make a pate is buy one of them I
don't know next one that called then you
have okay and then the next one when the
next one calls you tell the next one
that calls that I just did a shoot with
these guys and it turned out great you
know and then you've got a price and
then you've done two and once you've
done tubes at five and before you know
it you're the [ __ ] person who does
that for a living right and that's a
thing I wasn't I'm not really like I'm
at this point where I love the
photography I don't know this is it this
is it but how how am I gonna start
getting that door of the people coming
in to me and it's like okay well
patience I know honey I knew you were
gonna tell me that
you do you want me to tell you the
[ __ ] because there's a million
people doing that no I don't need the
Blake here's the real answer it's called
[ __ ] patience and more importantly it
might be when you say something real
quick it's about not being fancy right
like in your situation right now if you
want to put food on table kids all that
get another job to cool you can get a
job you could you could you could sell
stuff you could do something else when
I'm even more scared about is what
happens in 18 months when you're rolling
a little bit and you start getting fancy
I'm most scared in that one year of
transitioning where you went from the
weddings and now you're doing the yoga
and there's that one year where you
decided now you're fancy and it starts
breaking your behavior and you start
acting like you're somebody I think my
biggest question is me offering an
answer I probably already do know the
answer you know albeit at high chairs
all I want to hear from us I do I know
you actually do I know but can I say
something real quick go this is for so
many of you it's nothing you want to
hear it from us you're just still buying
time from eating [ __ ] people don't want
to eat [ __ ] you guys don't want to eat
[ __ ] do you understand you know the
answers you say you want to hear it for
me you don't want to hear from me you're
still blocking at doing the [ __ ]
thing that you don't want to do all of
me yes going out and saying hey I'll
shoot you for free is that it's
eventually gonna lead to something maybe
you suck [ __ ] at what you do I don't
know I mean I'm like I don't know like I
would hope so
under normal circumstances yes but if
you're the worst photographer ever no
here's the thing free or full price
never in the middle okay okay think
about that for a second because free
whose terms is that [ __ ] on yours right
full price who's getting paid you the
middle someone says what's your price
you say five grand they say I got 250
you say yes to that that's bet on you
yes or I'll do it for free you need 250
no chase I mean I think it's an
important listen monies listen listen
everyone you're you're right
in the philosophical standpoint but but
in our all realities we have an everyday
decision sure and sometimes you have
more leverage than the others which are
really easy to be a big shot when you
have eleven people wanting to give you
dollars much tougher to be cool when
it's the only person that's reach out to
you in three weeks which goes back to
what I care about most patients you're
trying to cash in on good behavior six
months in you are listen for this and
watch this backwards hey something good
starting to happen this is what I've
been doing for six or eight months cool
now when do I get to the glory never
invest in the process and then you're
[ __ ] there if you want photography so
much then this seems to be [ __ ]
awesome right it is you're trying to get
to the other side too quick exactly
while you've already figured out what it
takes
keep eating [ __ ] okay and build your
life organize your life so that you can
eat [ __ ] I see people that have studios
and they're hiring people and they're
like what in the [ __ ] you're getting
antsy around here it's but it's it comes
from a good place but it's gonna create
a bad outcome for you I come from a [ __ ]
place it's called insecurity you don't
need [ __ ] to look cool there's six
months I've actually condensed
everything down like good really I've
gotten rid of a lot of expenses and a
lot of different things I tell you when
I do doesn't matter how much money you
make if you're wasting it you're gonna
lose yeah all right you feel better
yes round of applause for you louder
that's a big
you got it thank you I love this
community humans me too yeah this is
super human every single industry I
spend my time in every industry it's all
the same [ __ ] it's all the same game you
know but in the creative community
there's this big bash laughs backlash
against free work I do free work every
day I make tens of millions of dollars a
year the end stop being so [ __ ] fancy
next victim I'm gonna go you right there
stand up against the post you sir and I
mean that and I mean that in a really
big way it makes me really sad cuz it's
such a great crap to have but because
you don't have as much business sense
you know theoretically which is not true
but often you start bashing against the
business part of this if you're such a
[ __ ] artist do it for free because
when you start charging you're in
business you better wrap your [ __ ]
head around that and this is business
dynamics you have a supply and demand
issue there's an unlimited amount of
talent out there and technology's caught
up and is armed every eight-year-old
with real [ __ ] ammo sorry sorry but
that's what's happened and until you
[ __ ] grasp that and fully absorb
they're sorry but that's the reality so
own it and go on the offense instead of
[ __ ] sitting on your couch and
dwelling every day
yes let's welcome Richard to the stage
thank thank you guys for picking me
appreciate it
Gary I've been doing a patience thing
I've been podcasting for 11 years
content creating a lot of sleepless
nights haven't made a dime and the thing
is it's like you know I want to support
my family keep board a nine-to-five
course I've been doing it you know
posting on Instagram in between my lunch
breaks writing posts for my site on my
phone yeah etcetera but what do you want
to happen let's start there what's
making it for you all I want to do is
review products write about video games
and podcast and get paid and get paid
how much have you reached out to ask
people for money for doing it I've been
reaching out let's let's be really
honest here because let's take advantage
of this moment yep how many hours in the
last 11 years on I'm asking you hours
have you spent emailing activision
emailing Sony emailing and saying I
would like you to pay me to review this
product at least 50 hours yeah in 11
years probably a little more than that
okay give it take and you've gotten
mainly knows some yeses but not
consistent and that's where the the
problem comes from it's you know playing
the long game playing have you a lot of
the free content you'll get it sure and
real quick for everybody there's
unlimited stories like this it comes
down to two variables either a you're
not good enough that the market wants to
pay because there's a lot of reviews
which hurts or B which has been
stunningly often you're not the person
that should be the business person you
should be the creative right what runs
through my mind is in your circle of
life is there some homie that could be
your 50% business partner where she or
he may spend all the time trying to
monetize the creative and 50 cents of a
millions a hell of a lot better than 0
of 0 1 is better than right that's right
true but no I that that's the thing like
you know I have people have been helping
me on a site for years yep you know I
built a podcast network from it doing
shows for other guys you know other
people that are on there giving other
people opportunities you know the have
you charged them maybe you're a platform
that Springs
talent instead of being the talent yeah
I have maybe or b2b business instead of
a b2c business yeah I haven't I haven't
charged them just because I was giving
people opportunities they started
writing they're like hey I wanted to the
podcast thing like you I gave them the
opportunity you know we got how many of
them gone off and done real thing oh
they're still they're still grinding
alongside me you know guys hit a hundred
shows already that 100 shows 500 show
yep but that's the thing it's like I
kind of feel like I'm spinning my wheels
is open so nobody was here and you were
with yourself in the mirror and it was
that moment to say why hasn't it
happened what would be the answer for
real don't [ __ ] me I think it's just
spreading myself too thin
okay more so than anything so stop doing
that have you tried doing a whole chase
I apologize keep going no you just like
being spread thin no no it's not it's
not a question of it's by choice it's
because it it's kind of forced
everything's by choice brother Oh
personal context I'll explain I've been
raising my two sisters they're both
handicapped
yes been doing it for the last 17 years
yes both of them are special needs yes
you know doing that Jerry a five job
being a husband yep you know doing all
that plus trying to grow a business
spreading yourself thin you know you I
work 40-hour workweek yep my wife spends
most time sleeping by herself but I'm
downstairs
yep wake up I go to bed at 5:00 a.m.
wake up at 9:00 a.m. go to work work
till seven o'clock
make sure listen this is not fun for me
to say guys but I want you to win
appreciate it there's a very fine line
between perseverance and delusion right
it's very thin 11 years and your
circumstance there first of all it
sounds like he can even tell you like
what you're doing I love what I do
right you might just have to settle into
that because when I am auditing this and
I don't know everything right but even
on quick intuition you might be better
off making money in some other way that
you're not seeing but there's a love to
the consumer-facing output that you're
making that you may want to not let go
of you might be able to make 80k at a
b2b business
what you're doing because it seems like
you have a lot of experience and you
could easily pretty quickly start
charging people $500 a month
teaching them 11 years of experience
that's super valuable times 80 people it
starts becoming a real business you just
might like the thrill of putting out an
output into the world and I want to say
this cuz we've done a lot of business
talk you know it's funny for me cuz
we're gonna create a place in business
world I spend all my time saying [ __ ]
money make a little less and do
something you like cuz you're miserable
you know me people I know make a million
dollars a year that [ __ ] hate their
lives a lot I'm not greedy I just want
to be able to make enough to provide for
my family that live okay right and just
be a provider that's it so able to
provide what are you from my audience
wow I think you're putting your talent
in the wrong place I have a funny
feeling you know my flip challenge I
have a funny feeling you'll make way
more money if you wake up at 6 a.m. on
weekends and go and garage sale and flea
market and Goodwill stores and buy
underpriced equipment in this industry
and flip it because you actually know
the value of all this [ __ ] ok like
you're gonna have to make a choice
between happiness and dollars because 11
years of data are staring you in the
face saying what you're doing isn't
working yeah I mean it's growing but
it's you know snow not a snail's pace
but not 11 years is a long time and so
you got to decide if you're not gonna be
the personal brand like what do you want
to do now do you want to accept it
because the love is so awesome or do you
want to transfer the skills and the
knowledge into something that's a more
monetizable reality and that's up to you
there's no right answer
maybe those nights are a lot of fun I
[ __ ] do talk like I think it's you
know like like I got lucky the business
savvy was my thing but like when I was
getting D's and F's and college was the
only way out I got [ __ ] on my entire
childhood cuz it wasn't good or cool so
like but I chosen I was willing to be
considered a loser for up to 20 years
old because I just couldn't breathe by
not the only thing at first I wanted to
do was buy and sell [ __ ] I find people
that trip up on three things one of
three things and I'm borrowing from
friend Tony Robbins so state story and
strategy you usually are effed up on one
of these three things mostly I find it's
a state if you can't have control your
state of mind if you're not hell
taking care of yourself in a good spot
it's very very hard for yourself to tell
yourself a good story because this is
required I'm good enough I'm enough as
Who I am right now to go out there and
put the work I'm valuable I can do this
these are stories and if your story is
like this is impossible I'll never get
there then you go back to state fix the
state first because you have to have a
good state tell yourself a good story
when you got the story part figured out
then strategy
I hear you oscillating a little bit
between story and strategy because I
hear a little bit of like I want to do
this 11 years bro
there's a lot a lot was the Nicole who
was just up here six months and she's
getting impatient you've been doing at
eleven years yeah I love that I love
that that tells me you've got a pretty
good state your story is good it's not
it's a little bit flimsy because it's
been 11 years now what I hear you not
innovating on is your strategy you're
trying to do the same thing and what
Gary's telling you is how can I make
money cuz it here is it here is it here
am i charging people for my MCM am i
reselling the gear how can I make the
living or the life or at first just some
money in that world it seems like you've
been doing the same thing and that's
funny no the money is there it's been
small like I said just small here real
quick we're gonna buy it that means the
money is not there right that means not
yeah it's not succeeding there's more
money far less start with that yeah the
money is there but it's small notes not
the money's not there to the
satisfaction that you want some people
want 50,000 years someone five million
the money's not there and that's okay
listen being an entrepreneur right now
has tricked everybody it feels like
anybody can do it it's super cool it's
super hard to build a successful
business absolutely it's super hard it's
an actual skill like the end like it
comes natural to some just like singing
just like having an eye for a photo I
don't see a [ __ ] blue jay and be like
oh there's an angle
I see a blue jam like [ __ ] that blue jay
you know like a like like these are
skills these are skills and like Richard
the data shows you that from a business
building standpoint you may not have
that skill
maybe it's yet maybe it's ever we don't
know you but the definition of insanity
is doing the same [ __ ] over and over and
expecting a different result right
you've got to do something different bro
do you do you is this clear like what
are you taking away from this
conversation well I think that I've gone
too wide I think he like Gary says and I
gotta go deeper on one one aspect okay
and just a lot of creative technical
interests well what's happening is it's
like you know you're putting out
podcasts so I've been doing that you
know doing the YouTube thing doing the
Facebook thing don't you stick with the
thing are you making a different video
every day on YouTube one is about vacuum
cleaners the other is about technology
and the third one no no I stay I stay in
my lane so you know it's tech products
games video games or saturated right
unlimited supply I'm super competitive
yep bigger do me a favor
how much how much money on this side
project would you like to make in a year
don't [ __ ] me what would get you
like holy [ __ ] not like I'm [ __ ]
buying islands like this really but like
this really matters to me this extra 5k
50 would give me a number as a separate
from my regular incorrect the thing that
would make you say [ __ ] this made it I'd
like to at least make ten thousand
dollars a month so you might think I
wasn't not being like I said not being
greedy just [ __ ] clearly let me help
you understand why that's greedy you
said ten to fifteen thousand on the side
do you understand we're a hundred twenty
thousand to one hundred eighty thousand
dollars a year puts you in the scheme of
100 percent of the people in America's
income okay and now you're being greedy
yeah and I need people to understand
that like like people don't get it right
like like that's it's it's a real number
we needed to find greedy if you're
making six figures a year you're making
a lot of money by standards and I know
New York might have different things
than that
but you have to wrap your head around I
don't think we sit and really understand
the data four hundred forty thousand
dollars a year put you at the bottom of
one percent the bottom of the one
percent the top
1% of everybody make 440,000 and up but
everybody starts talking like if I don't
make a million like we're not grounding
ourselves making $180,000 a year as a
side hustle is greedy as [ __ ]
I know finally you're entitled to be
greedy be greedy my man but I need you
to wrap your head around that first
right
look I think that you have to understand
you have to be in the sales and business
business not in the content business I
have a feeling that you have a very big
interest in all these things so it's a
lot more fun to make the content and do
the content than it is to run the
business yeah definitely more
labor-intensive I mean no not
labor-intensive it's what you like more
yeah yeah you know Big Brother you know
what I like to do slip into everybody's
DM and business develop yeah let's make
a [ __ ] deal like I make the content
as the secondary thing I don't like that
why do you think I don't [ __ ] edit
Nikko or babban or d-roc I don't give a
[ __ ] about the lighting I give a [ __ ]
about the game the hustle selling biz
Devon bringing value understanding how
it brings back and brand building a
brand leveraging strategizing where am I
going
selling doing sneaker drop plan of the
apps common it dipped into the good
business business business business
that's my hustle right that's why I make
money cuz I like the business part you
might be making tremendous content you
just don't have the business chops bro
get a [ __ ] partner Richard ok cuz you
can't do it rounds was the Richard
[Music]
[Music]
the business partner you know what it
what job my podcast is the very initial
my website is raised works that meant we
said when your check it out
rage works downtime rage works dotnet is
a site and the podcast that I do right
now is the variant issue it's a comic
book podcast but we have a full podcast
network of shows sports movies video
games we got it all you're about to get
form and then subscribe Richard do you
understand Richard
free from oh here in New York City Apple
Queens if I if I was his business
partner on his comic book podcast we
would make a million dollars a year
being serious I can't I can't I got my
own [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys thanks man
you guys you know how to get attention
get his attention
DM him he's Gary Vee pretty much
everywhere was to ease I don't know why
you did that bud but your worst branding
moved in my career to silent ease what
the [ __ ]
he's Gary I'm chase we're out of time I
wanted to say thank you guys very much
for coming out my name thank you man
thank you bye Thank You Jordan really
wants to know your two cents what's your
two cents
[Music]